this isn't the video I intended to make
it was supposed to be a review of the
Intel Ark A380 specifically this ASRock
Challenger model but that's not what the
end product would become ooh is it a
brutal takedown of the budget Alchemist
GPU no it's not that either if you like
stories with endings stories where every
question is answered and tied up in a
neat little bow I'm sorry to disappoint
you there is isn't a happy ending
waiting for you at the end of this video
what is then why am I wasting your time
if not to tell you one way or another if
a graphics SCS worth buying isn't that
my job after all well yes but I couldn't
do that this time this isn't a review or
a rant it's a cry for
[Music]
help
the plan was simple make the A380 video
nobody else has I was going to compare
it to a couple of other entry-level gpus
like the GTX 1650 super and RX 580 and
yes thank you that was a bold New Vision
for a review I know the thing I was
going to do differently was to try
pairing it with lower-end CPUs I've
heard from my friends over at Hardware
lab that Arc has a High driver overhead
and I wanted to establish whether that
would affect owners of older or cheaper
PCS the kind of customers a sub 150
graphics card might attract to set a
baseline I started my game tests as
usual in the moderately priced gaming PC
with the intent of then retesting them
with the ryzen 33100 later on as I
started entering the data into my
spreadsheet I couldn't help but notice
that this was bad really
really bad worse than a vanilla GTX 1650
in some cases 42 FPS in Spider-Man 52 in
fora Horizon 5 at medium 41 in Halo
infinite these aren't even 2023 Games
The Notorious titles designed to write
off 90% of the existing GPU ecosystem as
obsolete The Last of Us managed 35 FPS
at 1080 low with performance FSR
Starfield only hit 25 at the same
settings and this is the new update
which at the time of testing is still in
beta and don't get me started on Alan
weight 2 if these numbers were accurate
The RK 380 was far worse than I thought
but that was the question was this
accurate was the A380 really this bad or
was I doing something
wrong as absurd as that notion seemed
the final straw came in the time spy
test I usually include these as a
courtesy as I don't Place much value in
them myself but when it completed with a
graphic score of just under 3,100 I knew
something was up the average A380
Graphics score is about 50% higher than
this what
gives let's lay things out first and
foremost at the start of the test I was
using my usual PC a ryzen 55600 x 32
gigs of ddr4 3600 cl16 in the form of
two mismatched 16 gig kits a gigabyte
b550 gaming xv2 motherboard a V2 V5
Tower cooler A 1 TB WD blue boot SSD and
a 2 TB WD black game drive so far
nothing I've ever thrown at this setup
has suffered more than the occasional
CPU bottleneck it's not cutting edge Zen
4 and ddr5 but it should be more than
sufficient for a relatively low-end
GPU the possible explanations for this
problem fall into two categories
software and hardware for software I
first looked at the drivers from what I
understand of Intel's Graphics cars
they're still working hard to get
drivers up to scratch and updates are
arriving thick and fast sure enough the
4952 drivers I downloaded at 9:00 a.m.
had been replaced by the 4953 drivers by
900 p.m. and these are whql so if there
was a problem caused by the drivers then
surely these would be the solution
right well no the time spy score remains
stubbornly unchanged so whatever magic
was being done at Intel HQ didn't fix my
issue how about rolling back maybe the
old 4887 drivers from October will be
the solution it's not the first time
I've had to do this Nvidia Maxwell cards
developed a performance bug in Halo
infinite and Guardians of the Galaxy
that could only be resolved by rolling
back to older drivers again though there
was no improvement in the a380s time spy
scores I could have gone back further
and further through the archives but I
feel like if Intel's drivers had been
ruining GPU performance for more than a
month I'd have heard about it by now
there'd be
articles how about an installation
problem I always use ddu to remove
drivers between GPU swaps anyway but to
be on the safe side I ddu and
reinstalled 4887 to no avail I then did
the same with 49 53 and yeah no
improvement enough about drivers then
what about time spy itself perhaps the
3D Mark software package needed updating
and that way I was getting a terrible
score leaving aside the frankly even
worse implication that the A380 really
was this bad in games and that time spy
alone was the problem I checked the
software and there was indeed an update
I downloaded it and no no improvements
if anything that was actually a
relief by this point some of you might
be shouting at your screen but Iceberg
what about resizable bar you haven't
said anything about resizable bar
resizable
bar and to that I say yes thank you for
pointing that out this is my first ever
graphics card review and I'm exactly the
kind of [__] D forget to enable
rebar in an Intel GP test despite it
being explicitly recommended actually
when I posed the question in my
community tab someone did suggest
turning rebar off and I actually did
give that a try I mean it's not like
other computer problems haven't been
solved by turning things off and on
again but aside from Gaining about 100
points without rebar it wasn't really of
any major benefit I also tried manually
turning the PCI Express slot to Gen 4
and swapping pcie slots rebar are on my
system's in UEFI boot mode my drive
partitions a GPT I washed my hands and
said a prayer to Pat galinger and
nothing seemed to
work if changing the software wasn't
solving my problem the next best
solution was a change in Hardware I
don't currently have any Gen 4 systems
to hand other than my editing rig which
is a ryzen 75700 X on an Asus tough
motherboard with two sticks of Dom plat
rather than my Mongol Ram setup I have
on my test bench so I swapped out my
6900 XT in my editing rig for the A380
ddu my radon drivers and installed Intel
4953 opened up 3D Mark updated time spy
and CIS info ran the Benchmark again and
this time
bollocks in my despair I found myself
scouring online forums for anyone else
who'd shared this specific issue now and
as you might imagine looking for a
specific Arc problem online is like
looking for a needle in a stack of
needles I was lucky enough to find
someone who'd had a very similar
sounding issue with a Zen 2 chip and
that upgrading to Zen 3 resolved it for
them well that clearly wasn't going to
help in my case I already had zen3 but
it did raise the possibility that my
platform was the problem unfortunately
both my test rig and editing rig are AMD
right now the only other modernish
motherboard and CPU I had on hand were
an Asus z370 and an
i99900k z370 doesn't natively support
rebar though I do have an updated bios
on mine that enables it but it is also
limited to gen 3 speeds this could still
be a bottleneck the A380 only has an X8
interface but at this point I was
willing to give it a shot
regardless this was the last ditch
efforts one final Hail Mary before I
called it a day I moved the drives over
checked everything was working
reinstalled 3D Mark which had stopped
working for some reason and gave it one
last oh [__] it I'm done I don't know
what this card's problem is I'm sure
someone will give me a suggestion maybe
I missed something blindingly obvious so
do kindly give me your theories in the
comments sorry it was such a meaningless
video but I put more than a few hours
into this test and I guess I wanted
something to show for it even if it was
just a few minutes of me SC scaming into
the uncaring
void as for the A380 I guess I'll see if
I can get myself a refund and pick up a
Replacements and maybe I'll get to make
the video I intended sometime in the New
Year in the meantime if you got this far
thanks for watching kindly do the usual
YouTube things if you feel so inclined
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time